hey everyone dear volley here and in
today's video we are jumping back into
the dopast world that is gegeokutamis
jujutsu kaizen and going over the entire
izodory extermination arc that directly
follows after the aftermath of the world
altering shibuya incident arc obviously
so freaking much happened throughout the
last arc that has completely altered the
landscape of the story like gojo getting
sealed a huge number of sorcerers and
civilians dying including the nine to
five working goat nanami shibuya
district itself getting completely and
utterly destroyed all of the cursed
spirits that have teamed up with pseudo
ghetto getting either killed or
assimilated freaking toji for shiguru
got re-summoned at literally the height
of his strength sukuna's utter
domination and destruction and of course
the big and final reveal that was
braincon activating a countrywide idol
transfiguration therefore sending the
world of jujutsu back into the golden
age of jujutsu techniques obviously
there is so much more that i just have
not included so if you want to refresh
yourself before literally continuing the
aftermath of shibuya because that's what
this arc is the hype still somehow
continues it's literally insanity then
go back and check out that video that i
made like two or three weeks ago now and
also a few are new around here and wants
more content just like this where i go
over entire stories arcs fights and
pretty much anything from manga or anime
and way too much detail then make sure
you hit the subscribe button and also be
sure to leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with the algorithm
anyway enough of that let's finally get
into this arc so as we start back out we
see tokyo at night slowly as it zooms
out it reveals that the entire area is
now pitch black okay like giga straight
of a bat comes out and hits us with the
hanza hunter level of info dumb
literally like the text covers the whole
page and another complete double panel
afterwards anyways anyways random people
begin discussing this situation and
reveal that the 23 wards have almost
been completely destroyed by the way
these wards are like just like districts
or areas of tokyo that it's broken up
into because it's such a large place
anyways anyways these randoms who'll
probably introduce you to higher-ups or
japanese officials plan to create an
evacuation plan for 5 million residents
estimating that at least 10 million
cursed spirits have been released one of
them is flabbergasted that they plan to
evacuate the entire area wondering about
what the various consequences could be
another say is that they should expand
the two barriers to the boundaries of
the prefecture and another worries about
making public the existence of cursed
spirits which you know obviously
confirms that it's probably jiu-jitsu
higher-ups talking about this stuff
right here someone assures the others
that these sorcerers are protecting the
evacuees inside the city with another
adding that they can tell the public
that the cursed spirits only appear in
tokyo as someone else worries about an
intervention by foreign military the
others debate back and forth about how
to handle the situation with nothing
ever being cemented elsewhere at the
same time in a convenience store a young
girl kneels on the floor when she
suddenly spots a creepy figure in the
doorway telling her to come just
really weird when you put it like that
the confused girl asks where her mother
is and the figure replies that everyone
is all outside safe with him
she says in response that she doesn't
have a brother but the figure simply
repeats the girl's words which just
leaves her even more confused the figure
stays to come again and as the girl
walks outside a horrid cursed spirit
with razor sharp teeth opens its mouth
to devour her finally like i've been
waiting so long to talk about this dude
since i dropped my jk0 video people have
been asking where and like how what
happened to him you know like well here
he is leaping down from above the one
and only yuta akotsu suddenly appears
and stabs the creature directly in its
head with a calming smile on his face he
asks the girl if she's scared while also
making sure that she isn't hurt yuda
notes the area and doubts that she lives
here then noticing how worn her shoes
are he asks how far she's walked as yuda
tells her that she has done a good job
the curse suddenly rises up from the
ground and opens its mouth to devour him
but it's suddenly thrown back and
splattered against the wall as the girl
notices the attack luther asks reeker to
chill out a little while also covering
the girl's eyes and turning her away
from the carnage by the way like i
should mention i'm like 80 sure that
this is during the morning on the 1st of
november and maybe a day later but i'm
assuming that it's directly after the
shibuya incident arc because that's kind
of like how i've read it here anyway
anyway moving forward in the night yoona
meets with these so called higher ups
who praise his efforts however he
bluntly tells them to get to the point
one of them chuckles and says that is
killing of cursed spirits proves nothing
yudah asks in reply if he should enter a
binding vow assuring them that he will
follow through with any said plan he
says that since yuji itadori cut off
inumahi's arm during shibuya then he
will kill him personally as the meeting
ends five notices are made known by the
higher ups first ghetto is confirmed to
be alive and has been sentenced to death
again which is you know like kind of
funny but like obviously it's not ghetto
and surely they know that at this point
or like are trying not to believe it at
this point secondly gojo is considered
an accomplice in the incident and has
been permanently exiled removing his
sale would be considered a criminal act
this is obviously you know something
they want they don't want uh someone who
can threaten their power to come back
and actually kill them like kojo has
threatened them and they passed before
third masamichi yaga is to be freaking
executed for inciting gojo and ghetto
and causing the incident at shibuya
pretty much their thought behind this is
that he's their teacher he gets killed
because you know like he should have
taught them better pretty much or at
least you know like there is another
reason but we'll get to that later on
and not in this arc so we will wait for
that fourth yuji's execution will resume
now and be carried out immediately and
lastly yuta akotsu is appointed as
yuji's executioner so we've got a bit of
a main story character rivalry going on
here right now the prequel or main story
you know who's your guy's favorite
character out of gigas two main
characters anyway anyway skipping
forward to the zenith estates after
being critical of maki the misogynistic
jjk andrew tate this small man himself
naoya joins ogie and junichi as they
wait for the news about naobito's death
naoh criticizes his two relatives which
causes them to get aggravated after
naoya like these sly mofo he is defuses
the entire situation that he created
which is like more than andrew tate
could ever achieve a man named for a
darcy i hope i got there right i
probably didn't enters and informs the
three that the old man now be too has
passed away due to his injuries he reads
now beat his will and announces that
naoh will become the 27th head of the
xenon family and inherit all of his
assets once he is approved by either
oogie or junichi however in an utterly
bizarre twist of fate for adate then
reveals that there is a clause based on
a written agreement with toji it states
that if gojo has died or become mentally
incapacitated mikami fushiguru will
assume the role of head instead hearing
this naoya is left furious and knows
that the others would prefer to have
anyone other than himself as the head of
the clan he quickly learns from a female
attendant that megami is looking for
yuji in tokyo and tells her to inform
the higher-ups that he will kill yuji
personally in addition he plans to take
advantage of the chaos in tokyo and kill
megami to cement his role as the head of
the family skipping away from probably
my least favorite of the big three
families apart from you know maki and
mai of course but you know those two
babes come soon probably in the next arc
i'm pretty sure anyway flashing back we
find yuki on the phone with someone who
she apologizes to for not making a move
sooner she clearly remarks that she may
not necessarily be on their side adding
that she just wants to rid the world of
cursed spirits she says that she and her
comrades will take responsibility for
delivering the kids who were present
finally revealing that she plans to
confront tengen herself i'm guessing
that she's probably on the phone to a
bunch of higher ups like the same people
that called her in and you know if you
guys have any dope theories let me know
down below be super interesting if she
was actually talking or like in coats
with say a roommate or another of these
like mysterious characters because
that's just how she feels to me right
now she's a little bit mysterious and
still quite unknown like even even now
in the story so finally we make our way
over to yuji as he sits alone and
despondent on a large staircase josue
approaches him and asks about his
injuries but yuji says that he is fine
because it's kona but can also tell that
he is growing stronger inside of him
chosen says that he will be fined by
himself while he collects the remains of
his other family members and tells yuji
that he can return to jiu jitsu high
however yuji replies that sakuna has
something planned for megami and that he
himself has killed too many people which
again reminds choso of his murdered
brothers
calmly he says that it was a
misunderstanding and that forgiveness
isn't involved when it comes to brothers
then as the two head out to deal with
more cursed spirits both naoya and yuta
are seen moving out to track yuji down
and kill him standing alone on a bridge
yuji claps his hands together multiple
times to draw out several cursed spirits
he leads them down into an underpass
where chosu appears killing most of them
with a single shot from his piercing
blood the one romani cursed bird leaps
towards cho so but yuji easily crushes
it against the wall exercising the
cursed spirit having seen this chosen
was surprised by not only yuji's power
but his agility and control of cursed
energy describing him as a demon god
even though he still hasn't fully
recovered from the fights throughout
shibuya dude like literally is a demon
god he has the immortal king inside of
him brother cho so you gotta realize
that one man he calls yuji impressive
and addresses him as his little brother
once again which you know i absolutely
love yuji asks if he is going to
continue doing that and chozo answers
that he will adding that yuji's father
had stitches on his forehead which is
obviously implying that yuji's father
would have been brain kun and like oh my
lord i don't even want to talk about the
crazy ass implications that this would
throw into the story like if it is true
it's just mental suddenly naoya appears
above them and knows that he doesn't see
mega me as the two below notice him
naoya asks if they plan to run hearing
this though just leaves yuji slightly
concerned as he doesn't know why he
would to which naomi reveals that yuji's
execution will now resume since gojo is
no longer around to protect him taking
all this in yuji then remembers aino's
words about how there are many sorcerers
gojo has saved by protecting them from
the higher ups naouya tells yuji that he
doesn't care whether he lives or dies
since his business is with megami but
states that he can't allow him to be
moving around freely so instead he'll
incapacitate him and wait for megami
yuji asks what he wants with his
sorcerer to which naoy replies that he
plans for him to die preferably after he
writes something to help his cause in
that instant naoh leaps down and
although yuji notices his technique he's
unable to avoid a punch to his face
which seems them sliding back before
yuji or chozo can move in to land ahead
of their own naru quickly jumps away and
tells yuji that he is stronger than
expected and also wonders to himself
about the identity of the random man
with him now goes on to ask the two if
he should increase his speed but all
three of them suddenly stop when they
feel an overwhelming presence yuji
initially thinks that it's gojo but then
describes it as something far darker and
creepier he looks up and sees the big
man himself another of the extremely
freaking rare special grey sorcerers
yuta who calmly prepares his katana
while commenting on the fact that yuji
is not alone
as yuta unsheathes his katana yuji asks
who he is and chozo seems to recognize
his objective yuda jumps down from the
balcony and destroys a portion of the
wall on his way down leaving both choso
and yuji dumbfounded with his show of
destruction
slowly approaching him he asks who the
random is to which chozo says to yuji
that yuta must be his executioner nao
raises both his hands and assures akotsu
that he is on his side having heard the
name yuki recognizes him as the student
mentioned by megami and like gojo he's
also a special great sorcerer of
unfathomable power naoyu introduces
himself as maki's cousin saying that his
objective is to kill yuji as well he
assures yuta that he won't interfere but
goes to ask for something in return
while they do this chosen whispers to
yuji that he needs to run away since
they still don't know the trick to nail
your speed she asks if he will be okay
holding him off and as he releases blood
manipulation chozu tells yuji that he
has to focus on getting away from utah
pointing out that if he tries to fight
someone of that strength he will be
killed no matter what on the other side
now asks yuta to hold off on telling the
higher ups if he does kill yuji
revealing that he is bait for someone he
intends to meet back with the brothers
chosen whispers to yuji that he will
meet him at yesterday's spot to which
yuji agrees then quickly after yudur
agrees to naoya's plan leaving chosu to
him everyone suddenly makes their move
with yuta instantly sprinting past chozo
towards yuji chozo attempts to slow him
down with a passing bloodshot but naomi
manages to interrupt the attack yuji
sprints away from yuta each being caught
by surprise at the other speed as chozu
wonders if they guessed his last move he
readies up his blood manipulation once
again but naoya quickly strikes him
before he can use it although he is
unsure as to why chozo has the blood
manipulation ability naoyu remains
unfazed by it with the exception of
passing blood he ends his explanation
since the rest is obvious to him telling
cho so that it's now time for him to die
however chosen's mood changes as he
becomes serious and he asks naoya if he
thinks he will leave alive after he just
tried to murder his little brother it's
so funny like he's got like a crew of
these jacked up ass brothers following
him around making sure that he doesn't
die at the moment i absolutely love it
anyways anyways skipping away from the
underpass yuji sprints toward a car
resting on its side and loops over it
with you to quickly run into the other
side with his katana ready however yuji
grabs onto the car and transposes his
direction just barely dodging the attack
yuta is left stunned since he thought he
made contact telling yuji that he's just
like maki with his natural physical
abilities yuji then punches their car
towards utah and since he knows that he
can't win out in the open tries to run
towards a set of buildings however the
car is suddenly thrown back above yuji's
head stopping him instantly you ask yuji
if he is surprised since he doesn't look
like the strong type yuji recognises
though the enormous amount of cursed
energy pouring from him and realizes
that they too are polar opposites which
is you know like hella cool queen versus
king type thing i'd love to see like
more hyped feats from like rika and yuta
in general and sukuna as well and yuji
just so we can pair them up in this
massive battle to see who would come out
on top when they're going like full tit
against each other honestly like let me
know what you guys think down in the
description below i've always loved the
idea of these two just going freaking at
it for like hours on end kind of like a
like a one-piece battle of like a kainu
versus aokiji where they fought for like
seven days on an island and changed the
geography of their area like i love that
whole idea anyway anyway youtube then
reveals that while he has more cursed
energy than gojo the teacher's six eyes
allow him to reduce the curse energy
when he activates a technique to almost
zero allowing him to fight almost
indefinitely after yuda says that he is
done gassing up big gojo he sprints
towards yuji who while overwhelmed
remembers toto's words about an elite
sorceress flow of cursed energy and it
being difficult to read user then
strikes and seems to make contact with
his side of yuji's head but this student
quickly recovers and recognizes that
yuda's body and katana are constantly
surging with energy he tells himself
that the issue isn't his moves but the
fact that he is decisive with every
strike and can reduce any damage you
take to a minimum he remembers nanami's
final words to him and tells yuta that
he can't die yet however user keeps on
the offensive and although yuji dodges
almost all of his strikes one of them
grazes his cheek and opens up a cart he
realizes that he needs to do something
about yuda's katana he tells himself
that he doesn't need to fear blades if
he reinforces his body with cursed
energy but also can't overthink the
situation otherwise he'll end up dead as
he dashes towards a large suv he jumps
inside the open window and spots a knife
on his seat he quickly picks it up
before jumping out the opposite window
and continuing on running user leaps
over the hood and attacks him with his
katana though but yuji uses the survival
knife that he just picked up to block
the strike yuji is taken aback at first
and wonders where in the world did yuji
get a knife from but quickly realizes
that it must have been inside of the car
yuji then lunges forward to close the
gap and abuse the knife of cursed energy
trying to fight back he remembers gojo's
words about not relying on curse tools
to the detriment of his own cursed
energy's control as the clash continues
yuji knows that he hasn't learned how to
fight this way and then in a quick flash
yuda tells him that he is focusing too
much on his katana before raising it
above his head and kicking him in the
stomach sending him reeling back
you she can't believe the power of his
kick but even still he quickly recovers
user then follows up with an even more
powerful strike that breaks yuji's knife
and cuts into his stomach however did
you use the momentum of you to strike to
lodge his sword into the ground he then
follows up and pins it down and breaks
the blade with his thoughts which is
like insane by the way i i know this
isn't a curse tool or anything but still
it had you just cursed energy flowing
through it and most likely protecting it
in some kind of way even yuda is
surprised at first but calms himself
down while saying aloud that the fight
was never going to be easy
although yuji's wound is deep he tells
himself that his vitals are intact and
that both of them are now unarmed but as
he moves forward to strike a large
ominous creature suddenly appears behind
him and puts both of its hands around
his head she is frozen in fear and
youtube tells rika that they two were
just playing yuji he was like obviously
confused and doesn't know what to make
of it or the name or what's going on
wonders if it's a shikagami as yuji
struggles user tells rika to hold the
student still he then proceeds to calmly
stab him in the chest with a broken
katana as blood starts to drip from
yuji's mouth yuta looks him in the eyes
and apologizes inside of yuji sekuna is
completely caught off guard at first but
soon notices something and puts on his
malevolent smile
back in the underpass with another of
the parallels like just gonna add in
some more of my own brain cells right
here but i don't know why it's taking me
this long to realize both parties in
this arc are like parallels or like
opposites of each other in the regards
that choso loves his siblings where
naomi despises his yuta has raker and
yuji has secona like i find it pretty
interesting how giga always seems to
have a bunch of different themes going
on throughout each arc literally like
all at the same time anyways anyways
chosu struggles to keep up with the
speed of naoya who uses his basic pitch
version of projection sorcery to dart
around and hit cho so with a hard punch
to his guards reeling from the attack
chozu tells himself that he has no clue
what kind of curse technique naoh is
using and that he most likely won't
reveal it since he is winning so easily
naoya continues to overwhelm our boy
with strikes while chose her comments
that convergence isn't a viable option
since he can't even control the blood
outside of his own body mr big bad
zenning then compliments him on his
strength while asking exactly who he is
cho so in typical big profession
confidently says that he is the oldest
of 10 siblings before suddenly using the
ord over flowing red scale stack
changing their markings on his face and
causing new ones to appear by the way
the reason this technique literally like
shits all over carmo's new one is
because big choso has improved on the
basic version and pretty much made his
own kind of like what other characters
do with barriers and their own abilities
throughout the you know world after
chozu says that he is the oldest of the
10 siblings naoh clarifies that he's
asking about his curse technique and
toughness suddenly disappearing from
chosen's view cho so notices that blue
beside him though and quickly turns to
face the incredibly fast naoya who
realizes that chozu has focused flowing
red scale and the muscle of his eyes to
raise their sharpness so that he can
adjust to his speed however naoya easily
counters chozo's counter striking him in
the stomach and saying that he always
assumes someone will counter him first
as chosu recovers from his strike blood
suddenly begins to pour from an open
wound in his chest naomi reveals that he
decided to use a knife to affect his
blood manipulation asking him how long
he can continue to fight in that
condition oh
messed up here with just one damn thing
he disrespected his younger siblings and
doesn't even truly realize what cho so
is as well like i can't even believe
that at this point josue looks like a
pale zombie anyway anyway chosen
commends his plan when naomi continues
talking about how using hidden weapons
isn't considered cool he adds that many
do carry them around and are often
dependent on them saying that the way in
which his older brothers show off their
weapons is pathetic and how he was
always disgusted at the fact they feared
toji chozo mentions nao's dislike for
his brothers and now he says that the
older brothers who are weaker than the
younger brothers should just hang
themselves and die since they are
pointless which is so freaking wild man
like this guy's mind is so damn broken
at this point he needs help man someone
help him jose replies that new may be
the way he is now because of his
brothers and the way they treated him
twitch neo your scoffs at chosu's cliche
reasoning big bro choco continues by
saying that regardless of their strength
older brothers are role models and give
the younger brothers the chance to avoid
the mistakes that they make themselves
or to follow behind them if they go down
the right path he asks naoya to consider
the possibility that he is strong only
because his older brothers are weak jose
then reveals that he is strong because
he had no one older to guide him forcing
him to face his own mistakes and
continue walking ahead of his younger
brothers as the blood from chozo's wound
pulls at his feet and begins to blow
away from him now your back's up and
wonders how can he survive after so much
blood loss it's then finally explained
the death paintings have blood mixed
from cursed spirits and humans allowing
them to not die from blood loss since
they can convert cursed energy back into
blood choker then raises a wall of blood
which causes nalia to lose sight of him
however a slower slicing exorcism attack
comes shooting out of the blood which
now easily ducks below and comes to the
conclusion that chozo is finally dying
from the blood loss however chosen
suddenly appears several fake to the
left of mr misogyny and fires a passing
blood shot which he barely dodges but
quickly understands that he can't make
contact with while the wall of blood
still flowing toward him naoya barely
blocks a kick from choso and finds that
some of the blood has actually stained
his akama he wonders if the blood now
covering him is also affecting his
movement opposite him and standing tall
trojan prepares to fight another
piercing bloodshot as blood hovers
around him almost mimicking the wing
king ability that esop had possessed he
tells naoh that he knows what comes next
and that now it's checkmate naoy remains
confident and tells himself that he can
still move despite the binding effect he
tells choso to go ahead and fire but as
he dashes towards him he has a moment of
hesitation where he wonders why chozo
isn't releasing the attack as then
explained in a typical cutaway anime
manga style that the move choco would
use was his own so you all know a
of ability is about to go off created
after he honed his technique for a
hundred and fifty years choso then
releases a supernova attack causing a
large orb of blood to shoot out in
several directions and strike all over
the entirety of naoh's body leaving him
utterly finished chosu apologizes and
says they lost because he didn't love
his brothers however behind choso yuta
suddenly appears dragging an unconscious
yugi by his hoodie josue tries to react
but yuta effortlessly strikes him in the
side of the face which in turn knocks
him straight to the ground as naoh looks
up yuda says and what feels like a damn
degrading tone that he seems to be hurt
like oh you're okay down there little
nail your man you seem a little bit hurt
as user looks down on the wounded nayota
the letter glares back at him before
vomiting up blood he worries that
chosen's blood manipulation poisoned him
but assures himself that it isn't the
effect of a curse technique he then
realizes that cho so must be a full-on
curse because of how much blood he used
then guesses that his own body is
rejecting the non-human blood gouta
still standing above him offers to heal
him with his reverse curse technique if
he tells his superiors that yuji is dead
well that is the end of the battle that
takes place and finally wraps up all of
the madness that has literally been
going on for over 60 freaking chapters
but don't worry because imma finish off
this video with probably the most
freaking mind twisting and series
changing moment anyways a man named jyn
is seen holding their baby which is
obviously the big man himself yuji and
his daddy-o oh hopefully anyway the man
tells his father that if he wants to
talk about her he will just leave the
older man who's revealed to be yuji's
grandfather or suke itadori tells jinn
that while he can live his life however
he pleases he will die if he does not
give up on her
jin tells wasuke to not say such things
in front of eugene since babies
apparently remember more than most
believe
and you know like we're seeing that now
which is an example of that and i hope
we get other flashbacks like this stuff
revealed to us from like youtube's
parents because i want to know so much
more about this stuff here super
interesting to me unless none of it out
there was okay mentions the fact that
jin wanted a child with a normal woman
named kaori but before vasuke can
continue on about her death a woman with
stitches on her forehead interrupts him
and addresses him as her father-in-law
asking what he's talking about
okay so the flashback ends there but
well there's insanity did she have the
trial before branch took over or was it
after is brancon even in her head or is
it a tattoo i'm obviously assuming that
it's a brain cone in there and then it's
taken over during the pregnancy or
before yuji got pregnant she came back
from the dead and then bonked with daddy
oh and now yuji's here and that's why he
has the blood relation with chozo and
that's like kind of my thoughts on that
and real short but let me know yours
down below usually suddenly awakens next
to a fire as an emotionless uterus sits
nearby he's surprised that he's not dead
and user smiles with relief revealing
that goku had come to see him around
september and asked if he would watch
over yuji skipping back to then goku
tells yuta to take care of the first and
second years if anything happens to him
well akari should be fine youtube
wonders if gojo means getting a
girlfriend which is like randomly funny
since he can't imagine anything actually
happening to the big man himself goju
specifies that his primary concern
should be the first year named yuji
itadori gojiri then asks where miguel is
but yuda replies that he doesn't want to
see gojo and this is probably to do with
like miguel and the special rope that he
had during jjk zero you know like in his
fight that he had with gojo back in the
present yuda says that he put on an act
for the higher-ups so that he would be
the executioner in charge and know all
about the details of what's going on he
adds that to get approved as yuji's
executioner he had to enter a binding
vow to actually kill him a confused yuji
asks how he's still alive then to which
yuda replies that the very instant his
heart stopped he healed him with his
reversed curse technique he adds that
not many people even know that he has
the ability and guessed that it would
work on ug
yuda points out that because it's the
second time that yuji's death has been
staged the higher ups will learn the
truth soon but will consider his death
sentence complete for the time being
yuji wonders why he's doing all of this
for him and yuda replies that yuji is
important to people who are important to
him he tells yuji that he also used to
possess a power that he couldn't handle
but says that while he invited his own
upon himself usually did not and
shouldn't be blamed for that which is
you know like super wholesome from him
because he knows where he's coming from
yuji says that the blame isn't the issue
but before he can continue megami
finally shows himself and suddenly walks
out of the darkness while telling yuji
that they should head back to jiu jitsu
high before megami can finish mentioning
rejoining the oldest students yuji
interrupts him by telling him not to act
like everything is normal and nothing
happened youtube remembers yuji's words
about not being able to die yet and says
to himself that eugene is unsure whether
he deserves to live or not
realizing that it's the reason why he
held back when they two were fighting
yuji then yells out in pure desperation
that he has killed people and many
others are dead because of him but megan
me rebuttals that it's all their fault
telling yugi not to be selfish or give
up by himself as yuji stays quiet and
says to himself that he knew megami
would say that megami lets out his sigh
and says that they are jews who
sorcerers not heroes fighting for
justice he explains that they can never
be judged what they do and just have to
keep proving to others that they deserve
to exist adding that they can't think
about themselves with all of the other
people they have to save megami reminds
yuji that that was his original motive
but yuji closes his eyes and says that
it's because as long as megami is around
him he will suffer megami like the best
freaking mate you could ever have then
tells yuchi to start by saving him and
begsuji for his strength revealing that
braincon has started a culling game for
those with cursed energy and his sister
sakurami has awakened one and is now
trapped the culling game's eight known
rules are then explained by the way
there are like many more rules that have
been added or updated throughout the
current culling game arc this is just
the core eight rules that are first
revealed to them the first rule is that
players must declare their participation
at any given barrier within 19 days
after awakening a curse technique so
like people like sakumi this is why
she's in grave danger because she has to
go into a barrier and activate her like
jester participate in this coloring game
she has no other choice players who
break the first rule could have their
curse technique removed and this
honestly results in death that's what
happens when you run out of cursed
energy you die three non-players who
enter the barrier become players and are
considered to have declared their
participation upon entry
four points are scored by killing other
people
5. points are determined by the game
master with saucer is worth 5 points and
non-sorcerers worth 1 point players may
spend 100 points excluding the value of
their own life with the game master to
add one new rule seven the game master
must accept any new rule except those
that have a considerable and prolonged
effect on the game so literally like no
one can be like yo cancel the game or
end the game it's you can't make that
rule and finally the last one that has
been revealed so far
eight players have their curse technique
removed if their score stays the same
for 19 days so you know like there's a
whole
mixture of things going on right now
like sakumi is in mad danger she either
needs to kill people or they need to
implement some new rule that means they
can transfer points to people so she has
more points after 19 days and doesn't
die pretty much anyway anyway so that
officially brings us to the very end of
the entire itadore extermination arc
from jiu jitsu kaizen obviously this arc
was like insane with all of the
stuff that happened throughout it like
it's literally mind-blowing with yuji's
mum finally being revealed to us and the
fact that his brain can somehow like
when the actual
did that happen and how did it even
happen like who was who is what
i want actually that's literally what i
want to know at the end of the day
obviously i'm in the middle of freaking
nowhere again which i thought i do
because i am on holiday right now and
you know the video is out late which is
as per usual but surprisingly i'm
actually at the monument of tom cruise's
death after uh the last samurai so i
thought i'd show you all like this uh
historic and prestigious place that we
uh we decided to build after like the
historic movie that really raised our
country's gdp obviously if you guys have
enjoyed the video and want to see more
stuff just like this then make sure you
leave a comment down below and let me
know what kind of stuff you want to see
in the future like other series you want
me to go over fights or anything like
that obviously if you are new around
here as well then make sure you hit that
subscribe button but anyway for now it's
been your professional degenerate
diavolo and i'll see you all in a bit
bye